un parto por cesárea Generalmente
conocido como cesárea es un
procedimiento quirúrgico en que se
realizan incisiones en el abdomen y
útero de una mujer para dar a luz un
bebé
algunas cesárea se planifican Sin
embargo a menudo la necesidad del
procedimiento se torna evidente después
del inicio del trabajo de parto cuando
las condiciones anormales hacen que un
parto natural no sea seguro para la
madre o su bebé
las indicaciones comunes para el parto
por cesárea incluyen distocia placenta
previa y sufrimiento fetal la distocia o
trabajo de parto no progresivo
prolongado puede producirse cuando la
cabeza del bebé no cabe por el canal del
parto o su cuerpo se encuentra en una
posición desfavorable como por ejemplo
cuando está perpendicular al Canal del
parto o de nalgas como lo es la posición
de nalgas la placenta previa se presenta
cuando la placenta se encuentra en una
posición baja y obstruye de manera
parcial o por completo la abertura
cervical el sufrimiento fetal se produce
cuando la salud del bebé se encuentra en
peligro inminente por lo general debido
al flujo insuficiente de sangre a través
de la placenta O el cordón umbilical el
sufrimiento fetal puede producirse
cuando la placenta se separa de la pared
del útero antes del parto o el cordón
umbilical se comprime o estrangula
otras afecciones que pueden requerir un
parto por cesárea incluyen nacimientos
múltiples tumores grandes del útero
herpes genital u otras infecciones o
problemas médicos tales como la
hipertensión o la diabetes no controlada
el médico puede utilizar el ultrasonido
y un monitor cardíaco fetal que le
ayudarán a decidir si el bebé nacerá o
no por cesárea cuando sea necesario
realizar un parto por cesárea se le
preparará para una cirugía si aún no se
le ha colocado se le colocará una vía
intravenosa y se le insertará un catéter
en la vejiga para drenar la orina
en la sala de operaciones se la
anestesiará en la mayoría de los casos
se administra una anestesia espinal para
adormecer la parte inferior del cuerpo
sin embargo algunas veces se utilizará
anestesia general el médico comenzará
realizando una incisión en el abdomen
será una incisión vertical justo debajo
del ombligo hasta la parte superior del
hueso público o con mayor frecuencia una
incisión horizontal en forma transversal
y justo por encima del hueso público a
esta incisión en general se le denomina
incisión de bikini luego el médico
realizará una segunda incisión en la
parte inferior del útero Una vez que se
abre el útero su médico romperá la bolsa
amniótica si aún está intacta Y el bebé
nacerá el tiempo que transcurre desde la
incisión abdominal inicial hasta el
nacimiento es por lo general de 5
minutos
luego el médico pensará y cortará el
cordón umbilical
extraerá cuidadosamente la placenta y
suturará bien el útero y abdomen
Generalmente esto dura alrededor de 45
minutos por lo general la estadía en el
hospital después de un parto por cesárea
es de 3 a 5 días Durante este tiempo se
le recomendará que amamante duerma
cuando el bebé duerme y se levante de la
cama a menudo Aunque la mayoría de las
pacientes pueden ocuparse de su bebé
recién nacido después del procedimiento
la recuperación completa puede tardar
entre 6 y 8 semanas la cicatriz se irá
aclarando a medida que sane